that men on that man but maybe the
biggest story at a hall age though is
kind of The Return of the King because
they played the ready player one trailer
night and Steven Spielberg showed up it
was just like hey everybody remember
this zip [ __ ] your superheroes oh my god
this trailer is [ __ ] glorious it's
the mark described at bustling what'd
you say I was like what how do you say
it was like Spielberg getting to play in
Lego verse it's like there's the [ __ ]
Iron Giant in man is it DeLorean car
chase like how did that happen because
you're Steven Spielberg you're like I
want everything I'm 75 years old and
[ __ ] it give it to me good is he 75 yeah
he's up there are you [ __ ] me
[ __ ] - man I watched that trailer and I
was like this looks like it was made by
some young buck with vision [ __ ] 75
man he's like look kid I'm looking
backwards at this point so much so that
you at 46 are a kid that movie looks
like it was made by somebody who's at
the top of their [ __ ] game the prime
of their life and I'm certainly not
saying like all I've [ __ ] discounted
Spielberg ever but he's been lately
doing historical dramas yeah and I aim
weird [ __ ] kids movies and nobody
wants yes like he seems he seems to be
in his tusk phase where you know he just
wants to do the [ __ ] he wants to do and
he's like if they come along great if
not a man I'm having a good time and
then remembered like oh [ __ ] people pay
money for this year and then suddenly
came back with a movie that is
incredible like it that that won my
heart instantly and yes of course it
there's elements of like look at the
[ __ ] Iron Giant look it's the [ __ ]
DeLorean yes he's playing with IP and
that's and that seems delicious and we
know if you know Ernest Cline's book how
deep that goes and if you're a guy whose
name is in Ernest Cline's book you're
sitting there going I hope they [ __ ]
keep that in there you know
but it looks glorious man it looks like
it was made by somebody who's like I
have something to prove and that man has
nothing to prove but he's come back to
reclaim his throne
wouldn't it say it's coming out 2018
[ __ ] that's too far away
I'm sorry everything's 2018 I'm sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]